[Musique]
alger le 24 octobre 1954
un dimanche comme les autres pour la
foule qui profitent de repos
hebdomadaire mais c'est un grand jour
pour ces six hommes qui posent ensemble
dans l'histoire est l'objectif d'un
petit photographe de bab el oued
aussitôt après il se disperse aux quatre
coins d'algérie chacun porte une épreuve
de la photo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se met plus tard une série
d'attentats perpétrés simultanément à
travers tout le territoire ce coup là
nuit de la toussaint la guerre d'algérie
vient de commencer
troublé en algérie ou en plusieurs
endroits du territoire une série
d'attentats ont été commis dans l'année
qui est passé d'un à toussaint
on parle de fellaghas et de complot
organisé par certaines ligue musulmane
mais l'algérie ne se prêtera pas on
roule souhaité par les agitateurs on
peut croire que le gaz ne sera vite
rétabli
c'était il ya quarante ans le 1er
novembre 1954 la guerre d'algérie
commencer ce soir est brûlant de
l'histoire raconte l'insurrection de la
toussaint 54 les causes lointaines les
préparatifs secret le rôle des hommes
les archives filmées sont rares à
l'époque le clandestin ne convoquait pas
les caméras nous allons donc eu recours
aux témoignages difficile à obtenir du
côté algérien en raison de la situation
actuelle dans ce pays du côté français
trois hommes directement mêlé aux
événements apporte ce soir leur part de
vérité
pierre nicolaï directeur de cabinet de
françois mitterrand mise l'intérieur
jean deleplanque sous-préfet de batna au
coeur de l'insurrection des aurès jean
vaujour directeur de la sûreté l'homme
de tous les secrets enfin tout au long
de cette émission yves courrière
historiens l'auteur de l'histoire de la
guerre d'algérie apportera réflexion et
analyse il faut courir est ce que vous
avez un souvenir vous personnel du 1er
novembre 54
non absolument pas 1954 j'ai pas encore
commencé à être journaliste j'y pense
j'ai 19 ans et je ne me dit rien mais
pas de réaction particulière
en définitive votre question elle montre
bien tout ce problème de la première
partie de la guerre c'est que au fond
l'algérie on sait à peine ou sait et
tout le monde s'en fout alors comment et
quand vous est venue votre passion
finalement de la guerre d'algérie vous
êtes vous avez été journaliste sur le
terrain vous avez couvert la guerre
d'algérie oui j'ai été journaliste et
puis j'ai été militaire aussi j'étais
très très marquée par c'est par cette
guerre d'une part par les fonctions que
j'ai j avais rempli et d'autre part
parce que j'avais beaucoup d'amis
musulmans que toute ma belle famille
était pieds noirs et que j'étais pris
entre les deux et je me suis rendu
compte et que j'ai souffert si vous
voulez à l'intérieur de moi même deux
qualités cette guerre d'algérie et vu
mon âge
la guerre d'algérie avait été pour moi
jeune grand reporter ce qu'avait été la
guerre d'indochine pour mes aînés ou là
la deuxième guerre mondiale la
résistance
où la guerre d'espagne pour les aînés
pour entreprendre cette histoire vous
avez mené une longue enquête à l'époque
c'était presque à chaud c'était pas
longtemps après la fin de la guerre
qu'est ce qu'il y avait comme comme
source pour quelqu'un qui voulait
entreprendre cette histoire c'est à dire
qu'il fallait vraiment travailler en
journaliste j'ai fait là le plus long
grand reportage et le plus poussé de
toute ma vie il a fallu retrouver les
gens parce que bien sûr il n'était pas
question d'avoir les archives françaises
puisqu'ils la fameuse loi des 50 ans qui
me l'interdisait et que d'autre part il
ya lille a fallu retrouver les gens vous
avez écrit une histoire en quatre
volumes ce qui nous concerne
particulièrement aujourd'hui bien sûr
c'est le premier volume je vous l'avais
appelé les fils de la toussaint pour
écrire ce volume nous a menés pour vous
avez donc retour retrouver les
protagonistes des deux côtés et un peu
c'est un peu ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui en images puisqu'on va sur
vos traces essayer de voir comment
comment a débuté cette guerre mais je
crois que pour comprendre ce qui se
passe en 1954 il faut remonter au moins
en 1945 c'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
8 mai 1945 dans le défilé de la victoire
sur les champs-elysées l'armée d'afrique
est à l'honneur les milliers de nord
africains sont tombés sur les champs de
bataille de monte cassino de strasbourg
et d'ailleurs pour la libération de la
game ce sont des héros bardés de
médailles qu'on acclame à paris rabat
tunis où alger des héros qui retrouve
chez eux la supportable inégalités
ce même 8 mai à sétif de jeunes
nationalistes veulent profiter du défilé
pour affirmer leurs revendications le
drapeau vert et blanc fait sous la
pression des pancartes sont brandies la
policier perd son sang froid des coups
de feu y clame un jeune arabe c'est faux
aussitôt c'est les menus
en quelques jours des dizaines
d'européens sont agressés mutilé
assassiné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
tout de suite les européens s'organisent
en milices et se livrent à des
représailles zaven l'armée sous les
ordres du général duval mène une
répression terrible impitoyable on parle
officiellement de 15 cents victimes le
bilan réel est beaucoup plus lourd
la somme on dit que la guerre d'algérie
avait commencé à ces types parce que ces
vérités oui je crois vraiment qu elle a
commencé ce jour là là c'est vraiment
spontané c'est la haine qui va qu'il va
éclater d'un coup ce sera rien à voir
avec ces grandes manifestations dans
l'est algérien
qui auront lieu
en 1955 au 20 août alors là où ça aurait
été vraiment quelque chose ait un
massacre préparer là non combien
d'européens pas de français européens
qui sont massacrés de recycler quelques
jours alors là on peut dire que pendant
ces deux jours autour de 8 et 9 mai il y
as je reprends les chiffres exacts de la
commission denquête il y à 104 européens
qui ont été tuées et il faut bien dire
les choses comme elles sont c'est que
quand
il y à ces morts et donnant des détails
qui sont qui sont épouvantables mais et
femmes sont violées on retrouve même une
pauvre femme de 84 ans qui a été violée
les hommes quand ils sont tués c'est le
ventre ouvert les parties génitales dans
la bouche je veux dire que quand les
militaires français ou les gendarmes
découvrent des spectacles pareil
qu'est-ce qui se passe bon c'est une
bouffée d'adrénaline
épouvantable après le massacre via la
répression à leur gala répression et la
répression va être vraiment imbéciles
aveugle et là on va on va tuer pour tuer
depuis 45 et une controverse énorme sur
les chiffres de cette répression alors
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut dire que
ça les chiffres se balade entre 800 et
45000 donc je pense que comme la france
a fait à l'époque une commission
denquête on en pense qu'on en veut mais
il ya quand même les chiffres les plus
ils ont les plus minorés alors ces
chiffres voilà voilà ce qu'ils sont
c'est la commission denquête elle a été
faite par un général qui est un général
de gendarmerie qui s'appelle tubert qui
est un homme plutôt libérale m'enfin
tire pas non plus un enfant de coeur et
lui qu'est ce qu'il donne il donne ses
104 européen tué 5 à 6 ans indigènes
tués par l'armée dit le rapport cinq à
sept cents indigènes tués par les colons
parce que là il ya eu cette répression
aveugle il ya des colons qui dans le
bled se sont sont déjà armé ou se sont
armés envoyés soit exactement ces
milices et là on va tuer complètement
aveuglément pétales total bon qu'est ce
que ça fait
un gros millier mais en définitive le
général tubert ça c'est ce qu'il a écrit
et puis dans les conversations dit non
ça a été beaucoup plus terrible que ça
et il estime à peu près la répression à
15000 morts quinze 15 mille morts
algériens alors bien sûr le fln plus
tard se servira de ces massacres de
sétif et on dira il ya eu 45 mille morts
il ya eu 55 miller il ya eu soixante
mille morts le du côté algérien on s'en
tiendra on reviendra au chiffre de 45
morts 15 mille c'est un chiffre qui est
à peu près sûr heureusement mais c est
exactement mais il ya une chose qui est
à dire qui est importante c'est que à
partir et c'est là où on peut dire que
la guerre d'algérie elle commence à
sétif c'est qu'à partir de sétif il ya
un fossé qui commence à se creuser entre
la population européenne dans la région
a uniquement dans la région entre la
population européenne et la population
musulmane il ya un mot moi qui me qui me
frappe c'est c'est un mot de ce grand
écrivain kateb yacine il dit
c'est à sétif il avait 16 ans et au delà
c'est à sétif que ceux-ci manta mon
nationalisme et je pense que ce
nationalisme beaucoup beaucoup
d'algériens qui le verront naître tout
comme kateb yacine vous avez tout de
suite là tous les partis des dacquois
risque a eu comme tester les réactions
en france sur ce massacre on en a très
très peu parlé et ça c'est le problème
éternel de la france en tout cas dans
ses débuts de la guerre d'algérie comme
je vous le disais un peu trivialement en
commençant cette émission en france pour
mon sens
[Musique]
je vous ai donné la paix pour dix ans
avait prédit le général duval n'a fait
qu'accélérer la prise de conscience
nationaliste qui s'exprime dans trois
courants distincts le mouvement des
oulémas les docteurs de la loi coranique
fédérer depuis 1931 par le cheikh ben
badis les oulémas partisans d'un retour
valeur morale de l'islam étendent leur
influence par l'ouverture d'écoles
coraniques il contribue fortement à
donner au nationalisme algérien ses
racines culturelles
messali hadj le prophète barbu et
charismatique et la figure dominante du
nationalisme révolutionnaire entre exil
et prison dirige le ppa parti populaire
algérien créé en 1937 dissous en 39 mais
qui continue une existence clandestine
[Musique]
ferhat abbas enfin un modéré pétri de
culture française qui a longtemps cru à
l'assimilation avant de réclamer en 1943
dans son manifeste du peuple algérien un
état autonome associé à la france
ferhat abbas arrêté au moment des
émeutes de sétif libéré un an plus tard
créa parti lui dma qui montre sa
représentativité aux élections à la
constituante
dès juin 46
[Applaudissements]
messali en novembre de la même année 46
de retour d'exil créé à son tour à parti
légal le mtld mouvement pour le triomphe
des libertés démocratiques qui rentrent
en 33 % des sièges aux élections
municipales de 47
ce succès est frais car entre temps à
paris la quatrième république enfin
installé dans sa constitution a voté un
statut pour l'algérie
ce statut qui comporte des mesures
libérales maintient le découpage en
trois départements sous la houlette d'un
gouverneur général
[Musique]
prévoit la création d'une assemblée
algérienne formé par le collège de 60
mans
au premier collège représenter 860000
français le second les 8 millions de
musulmans les inégalités demeurent et
c'est un progrès qui inquiète les
tenants de l'immobilisme
[Musique]
le statut doit être ratifié à la
majorité des 2/3 ans l'assemblée
algérienne
pour élire la première assemblée
algérienne l'algérie tout entière a voté
2 millions d'électeurs sont allés aux
urnes les premiers citoyens français et
notables musulmans votant pour le
premier collège où les candidats unis
par l'idéal républicain les français
sont arrivés en tête
les autres musulmans a beau temps pour
le second collège où les partisans de
messali et de ferhat abbas ont essuyé un
échec premiers résultats la raison
triomphe en algérie et l'union française
s'organise
[Musique]
les adversaires du statut donc de
l'évolution en gagner mais il a fallu
bourrer les urnes le nom de gouverneur
général naegelen restera associé à la
fraude électorale les mêmes
tripatouillage se répéteront aux
élections de 1951 le statut de 47 votée
par l'assemblée nationale ne sera jamais
appliquée c'était peut-être la dernière
chance une évolution centrale
en réalité derrière le pouvoir politique
les influences quelques grands colons
sont les vrais maîtres de l'algérie
comme henri borgeaud sénateur radical
rend propriétaire terrien il règne sur
6000 personnes qui travaillent dans ses
vignes et plantations d'agrumes de tabac
ses usines de ciment
comme encore georges blache est le roi
de l'alfa qui apportent par ses
exportations 20% ces devises à l'algérie
possède le journal d'alger
enfin laurent schiaffino d'origine
napolitaine il a la tête d'un empire
flottant dans chaque bateau porte le nom
n'a membres de sa nombreuse famille
président de la chambre de commerce et
possède lui aussi un journal dépêche
quotidienne
[Musique]
tous les européens ne sont évidemment
pas milliardaire le petit peu que
pieds-noirs prolétarisés a en général un
niveau de vie inférieur à celui des
métropolitains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on retrouve également une forte
disparité chez les musulmans deux
millions d'entre eux mais dp6 d'une
relative aisance les autres la majorité
souffre de la pauvreté de la misère même
une scolarisation insuffisant 16 % des
enfants de gisements seulement vont à
l'école
l'explosion démographique accentue les
inégalités allongent les files de
chômeurs
il faudrait à tout cela beaucoup
d'imagination pour se sentir des
français à part entière
[Musique]
des grandes figures de la contestation
ces deux figures croisés et
contradictoires d'ailleurs c'est ferhat
abbas d'un côté et messali hadj et
l'autre est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
d'un côté le le réformiste et de l'autre
le révolutionnaire
où il ya du vrai là-dedans disons que
l'un sait faire à tabac se faire à tabac
c'est un politicien d'un politicien de
la troisième république de la quatrième
république il a un côté d'aspect déjà
physique à côté très rock et costume un
peu avachi la poignée de main facile etc
mais c'est un homme qui avant la guerre
voulait lui absolument la
nomination et puis il s'est rendu compte
que personne
exactement elle va très vite et après la
guerre il n'en veut plus il a créé un
parti qui s'appelle l'union démocratique
pour le manifeste algérien l'udma et
demi qu à lui alors lui il veut que ses
saillies doucement mais que nous allions
en algérie vers un pays qui soit libéré
du colonialisme veut pas mettre du tout
les européens deux heures mais il veut
aller tranquillement vers l'indépendance
et c'est un homme qui fait peur aux
européens disons aussi les plus les plus
évolués les plus importants
politiquement parce que ils se disent
celui là il est trop poli il est trop
modéré les trop poli pour être
profondément honnête il faut s'en méfier
et face à ça il ya messali hadj alors
vous seriez adjoints n'ont pas du tout
pas du tout messali hadj il lamballe les
foules musulmanes mais les européens le
connaissent très peu et puis le méprise
un petit peu d'abord messali hadj iata
pratiquement il est toujours en prison
c'est un homme qui est un ancien
communiste il est passé dans les années
30 par ce creuset formidable de la
politique qu'on retrouve dans tous les
pays et que ce français qui a été le
creuset de renault il a travaillé comme
manoeuvre chez renault il a appris
exactement et puis il a été un petit peu
plus loin quand même dans ces études si
j'ose dire puisque on retrouve sa trace
on retrouve sa trace dans différents
endroits on le retrouve à bruxelles on
retrouve au caire on retrouve à moscou
où il s'est fait exactement liés disons
qu'il est ni agitateurs me mis cinq
hommes parce que on se déplace c'est des
foules entières qui ont une audience
énorme audience est d'ailleurs alors lui
il va pas avec le dos de la cuillère il
se fait ils se baptisent el sayegh
l'unique est lui
vraiment il veut l'indépendance dès 1937
il a créé son parti qui est le parti
populaire algérien il a fait peur à ce
moment là on a supprimé on a interdit le
parti et depuis il est clandestin et
alors là c'est à ce moment là en 1946 il
crée un parti qui va être la couverture
du ppa qui est clandestin et ce parti ça
va être le mtld dont on a beaucoup parlé
ça veut dire le mouvement pour le
triomphe des libertés démocratiques
paravent démocrates voient la selle par
amandine nos pratiques et ça va être un
triomphe d'ailleurs pour messali hadj
aux élections municipales de 1947 et là
on va en parler parce que va commencer
une deuxième cause de la guerre
d'algérie c'est que il ya bien des
élections des élections démocratiques
mais à chaque fois qu'est ce qui se
passe eh bien on voit des élections avec
des urnes qui sont déjà remplies je veux
pas dire à ras bord mais pas loin deux
buts un préfet il ya le fameux statut de
40 celles qui marqué des progrès timide
mais réel en fait il n'est jamais
appliquée elle n'a jamais appliqué ce
pour eux c'est pas difficile d y aller
parce que on revient à ces grands
groupes de pression chez ces gros colon
qu'ils font dix ans qu'on pourrait
appeler de l'obstruction colonialiste à
l'assemblée algérienne il suffit de
tenir la majorité pour que ce statut
soit jamais appliquée et c'est très
exactement ce qui va se passer les
élections à l'assemblée algérienne de 48
on a vu le sur les images de
commentaires qui annonce la défaite des
partis des partis nationalistes
évidemment ces élections alors là on
conduire vraiment que tout est rose
intervention il ya des bons candidats
engagés les chiffres ici des bons
candidats qui sont élus à 98 99 cents et
même sans 2% des voix et comment vous
expliquer cette sorte de l'incapacité de
la métropole de la france de réformer
alors qu' un mouvement de général de à
ce moment-là de décolonisation pourquoi
il ya une telle cécité sur ce qui se
passe en algérie parce qu'on ne veut pas
le voir parce qu'on est encore sous le
régime des partis il faudra attendre la
cinquième république et 1958 parce que
les gouvernements pour vous dire entre
1945 et le 13 mai 1958 avec l'arrivée de
de gaulle il y aura 16 gouvernement vous
rendez compte un gouvernement qu'est ce
que ça fait c'est six mois on a perdu
complètement l'habitude on s'en souvient
plus moi je m'en souviens encore et il
ya beaucoup de français qui s'en
souviennent encore cette époque-là bon
gouvernement a absolument besoin d'avoir
une majorité et cette majorité il la
trouve chez des gens comme rené meyer
chez ces groupes de pression chez ces
gros colon
chez ces élus
[Musique]
la chute de dien bien phu
7954 provoque l'arrivée au pouvoir de
pierre mendès france
dans le gouvernement qu'il présente au
président coty françois mitterrand
reçoit le portefeuille de l'intérieur
qui comprend l'algérie
à peine pierre mendès france at il signé
les accords de genève mettant fin à la
guerre d'indochine il est confronté aux
troubles en afrique du nord le maroc est
en ébullition et la tunisie s'agite
le 31 juillet mendès france et à
carthage il fait connaître au b les
propositions françaises qui tente à
accorder au peuple tunisien son
autonomie interne
on
l'algérie en cette année 54 cents de se
tenir à l'écart de cette agitation mais
le ministre de l'intérieur ait décidé
amorcé les évolutions nécessaires pierre
nicolaï directeur de cabinet de françois
mitterrand est chargé de prendre des
contacts
ce qui m'a été dit et redit à plusieurs
reprises à chaque fois que général jerry
avant c'était que l'algérie ne
connaissait pas de problèmes politiques
uniquement les problèmes économiques ce
qui signifiait donnez nous de l'argent
et laissez nous gouverner
c'était ça la base fait bon effet dans
ce climat là que j'ai cherché encore en
cas d'accord bien entendu avec françois
mitterrand a essayé de faire évoluer
l'algérie une évolution qui pourrait
s'être totalement inéluctable et le
thème général de nos réflexions c'était
encore très très loin de ce qu'ils
étaient arrivés par la suite mais enfin
le thème était à voir vous trouvez dans
la dans le monde musulman une élite qui
pourrait
un beau jour du goût le plus vite
possible arrivée à prendre des
responsabilités
c'est à dire avoir des interlocuteurs
alors que jusqu alors les interlocuteurs
du mouvement général d'alger c'était des
personnages qui était en quête davantage
ou de décoration c'est à dire il
comptait pas politiquement
il est déjà bien tard les interlocuteurs
valables on essaie de tirer les
sonnettes d'autres dans l'ombre se
prépare à l'action
là il faudrait revenir très rapidement
et dire qu'à l'intérieur du mtld il ya
un mouvement qui s'est formée qui
s'appelle l'organisation spéciale cette
organisation spéciale elle s'est faite
parce que une partie des durs du mtld on
est des activistes en ont eu assez de
voir toutes ces élections truquées dont
nous avons parlé et ils ont décidé de
créer un organisme qu'ils soient
spécialisés dans la révolution c'est ce
qu'on appelle l' os l'organisation
spéciale dans cette es en 1950 on peut
dire que cette organisation a été
démantelé mais en définitive elle a
politisé des hommes parmi lesquels on va
retrouver les fils de la toussaint ou
d'autres comme ali mahsas ben bella et
d'autre et eux
ont été soit fait prisonnier et se sont
évadés soit on réussit à échapper à la
police mais c'est à partir d'eux que va
vraiment se crée la révolution va se
faire le crua qui s'appelle qui est le
comité révolutionnaire d'unité et
d'action qui est l'ancêtre du fln
au printemps 2009 154 le mtld le parti
de messali hadj traverse une grave crise
interne
des militants se déchirent entre fidèles
du vieux prophète et partisans de son
ancien lieutenant laouen
lassé de ces querelles intestines un
petit groupe de militants convaincus de
la nécessité de la lutte armée décide de
créer un instrument de l'insurrection ne
crut à ses fondateurs sont les chefs
historiques et fils de la toussaint et
sont tous recherchés par la police rabah
bitat 28 ans mostefa ben boulaïd 37 ans
mourad didouche 32 ans mohamed boudiaf
35 ans belkacem krim 32 ans larbi ben
m'hidi 29 ans ces hommes jeunes ont
décidé de changer le cours de l'histoire
il court hier c'est ici dans ce café au
carrefour de l'odéon que toute cette
histoire a commencé on peut dire et bien
en partie oui parce que ya là deux fils
de la toussaint qui vont rencontrer un
troisième homme ses deux fils de la
toussaint sont mohamed boudiaf didouche
mourad et qui viennent rencontrer un
garçon qui s'appelle ali mahsas et
alluma saas
représentent une partie du mtld en
france
c'est au printemps 1954 c'est ici que
halima sas va avoir comme mission de
faire en sorte que la population
musulmane de france qui est fort
nombreuse s'intéresse
à la révolution s'intéresse aux mtv
moment là boudiaf a décidé de créer le
crua le comité a embauché dans l'unité
d'action alors mohamed boudiaf il a 35
ans c'est un constantinois un homme qui
est cultivé c'est pas du tout un petit
berger du bled c'est un ancien militaire
il est adjudant il a fait la guerre
il a la médaille militaire il à la croix
de guerre il a été condamné en 1950
l'autre garçon qui est beaucoup plus
jeune didouche-mourad il a 27 ans lui
c'est un algérois il est de familles
aisées ses parents et est aisé il a été
arrêté en 50 il s'est évadé et lui aussi
est un clandestin alors il ya d'autres
garçons qui viennent se greffer
là-dessus qu'ils sont tous des anciens
os il ya rabah bitat qui à 28 ans qui
est inconstante in war qui est vu alors
d'une famille tout à fait misérable
condamné à mort en 50 clandestins etc à
l'univers comme avant sur tous des bons
pedigree or ils sont tous vraiment
démériter militants qui sont prêts à
mettre leur peau d'où leur idée ça
nombre d'entre eux vont le faire puisque
n'aura pas tellement de survivants des
fils de la toussaint il ya un autre
homme qui est très important qui est
mostefa ben boulaïd ben boulaïd et c'est
un s'étonne ces algériens un petit peu
curieux et qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les arabes d'algérie qui n'ont rien à
voir avec
seal si ce n'est un lointain cousinage
avec les kabyles qui sont ceux qu'on
appelle les chaouia les chaouia des
zoreys sénat c'est ce sont des gens qui
de tradition il ya une formidable trod
tradition des bandits d'honneur comme
comme on l'a eu encore ce jusque là la
troisième république
donc lui c'est un homme tout à fait
décider alors le dernier maintenance et
krim belkacem c'est l'apport de cabine
krim belkacem c'est un homme qui a 32
ans et un kabyle c'est un fils de caïds
alors un caïd je rappelle rapidement ce
que c'est c'est dans ces communes du
bled s'il est à la fois juge
administrateurs c'est lui qui dirige un
petit peu la police et krim belkacem lui
alors il c'est eux
véritablement dressé mais de toutes les
fibres de son être contre cette
politique de désir ne truque et kick ass
est absolument tout espoir aux gens qui
comme lee voulait faire quelque chose
avec leur pays ils voulaient voir leur
pays allait vers l'indépendance mais si
l'on ne parle et qui font figure sur
cette photo historique était prise
avant l'insurrection il faut ajouter
trois autres noms qui sont en terrain
connu aujourd'hui son benbella aït ahmed
et validés alors mohamed khider c'est un
homme lui qui est tout à fait comme
ferhat abbas il a été député élu député
d'alger depuis 1946 il s'est enfui à
l'expiration de son mandat et c'est un
homme qui représente le mt lt au caire
ahmed benbella lui aussi sait voilà
encore un qui est adjudant médaille
militaire croix derrière sinon cetera
cassino qui c'est qui a combattu
véritablement comme comme à lyon et qui
en 1950 était un des responsables de l'
os l'organisation spéciale qui a été
arrêté qui s'était évadé en 1952 et kit
qui a été le chef de l' os de même que
hocine aït ahmed qui est le troisième
qui lui est kabyle qui est un fils de
caïds un homme qui est de loin de sur
les des neuf et six fils de la toussaint
et les trois du caire qui est de loin le
plus lettré certainement le plus rhdp
anisé et disons le mot certainement le
plus intelligent pour la petite histoire
pu dire quand même que oui c'est un
homme dont on parle aujourd'hui face au
fils est l'homme du parti socialiste
kabyle disons que c'est l'homme en tête
dans cette kabylie qui en ce moment est
en train de se lever on le voit dans les
colonnes des journaux alors ces trois-là
au caire il représente le mtld auprès de
la ligue arabe mais la ligue arabe
auprès d'elle il ya tout tout c'est
parti pas seulement algérien hassen
c'est bien de tout le monde arabe dans
tout ce qui bouge alors disons qu'il ya
surtout beaucoup de palabres et pas
grand chose d'autre ya une chose qui est
beaucoup plus importante c'est que ben
bella lui c'est lié avec gamal abdel
nasser qui est le patron de l'ensemble
le tout le tout récent patron de
l'egypte et surtout avec fathi al dib
qui est le chef des services spéciaux de
nasser et fathi el dib qui est disons il
est copain avec ben bella lui dit
d'accord on vous aidera il faut vous
montriez ce que vous voulez faire il
faut que vous commenciez vous même la
révolution et que vous restiez pas dans
votre coin comme ça a continué à
palabrer alors il faut vous fassiez vos
preuves
depuis le printemps 1954 les six chefs
du crua se rencontrent régulièrement
dans les lieux secrets de la casbah
d'alger et recrutent des chefs de
commandos chargés à leur tour de trouver
des hommes qui ignore l'identité des six
chefs le 3 juin les fils de la toussaint
se répartissent les zones et prendrons
plus tard le nom de wilaya à ben boulaïd
la zone de l'aurès à mourad didouche la
zone 2 du nord constantinois à belkacem
krim la zone 3 de kabylie à l'habitat la
zone 4 de l'algérois larbi benmhidi la
zone 5 de leur année
mohamed boudia pays du président du crua
d'assurer la coordination et la liaison
avec les représentants du caire
25 juillet en l'absence de belkacem krim
et cinq chefs réunissent lors 17
vêtements au clos salembier sur les
hauteurs d'alger lors de cette réunion
historique et pam deux se prononce pour
le déclenchement des six mois la lutte
armée jusqu'à l'indépendance à l'automne
après avoir déterminé un certain nombre
d'objectifs pour le jour de
l'insurrection une charge de leurs
hommes de fabriquer les beaux ils
ignorent que depuis quelques temps déjà
ils sont sous la surveillance de jean
vaujour directeur de la sûreté à alger
et que l'artificier qu'ils ont choisie
est un indicateur
[Musique]
nb commissaire manipuler un informateur
qui était dans le groupe dit de la
casbah et un jour il est arrivé en
nous disant dit notamment commissaire on
me demande maintenant de
préparer des bombes avec des explosifs
alors le commissaire m'a dit qu'est ce
que je dis à l'informateur et j'ai dit à
ce commissaire vous avez une femme
pharmacienne demandez lui s'il ya un
produit qui pourrait faire du bruit mais
pas de mal et c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle l'a dit et qu'elle nous a fait
dire qu'il fallait employer du chlorate
de potasse en a donné ce tuyau si je
puis dire un autre informateur qui a
fabriqué un cerf d'une certaine centaine
je crois de bombes comme ça avec
déplorable de potasse il faut bien là si
je comprends bien les bobos d'alger ont
été préparés selon les indications
exactement j'ai même sorti deux mille
francs de mon portefeuille pour acheter
leurs actes potasse c'est vous qui allez
payer en pousser
à la mi octobre 2010 l'intérieur
françois mitterrand bien se rendre
compte sur place des dégâts causés par
le violent tremblement de terre qui a
ravagé en lait en ville le 9 septembre
les loin de se douter qu'une
insurrection est imminente de toutes les
autorités locales lui tiennent des
propos rassurants
[Musique]
le 18 octobre le remet la légion
d'honneur raymond latière président de
l'assemblée algérienne et lapierre a
remercié en prononçant cette phrase
monsieur le ministre
n'écoutez pas la voix des sirènes qui
vous disent que l'algérie risquerait
d'être contaminé par ses voisins
je peux vous dire aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre que l'algérie et calmes et
qu'elle le restera
à la fin du voyage ministériel vaujour
qui semble être un des seuls à s'alarmer
prévient nicolaï
bonjour m'a pris à part à l'aérodrome et
m'a expliqué que à ses yeux c'était pour
les premiers jours de novembre
il avait
décelé
des complots d'un an petit nombre de
nigériens qui se préparait à faire un
coup et là mes [__] un petit nombre est
allé à ce moment là il m'a dit mais ce
que je voudrais savoir c'est que j'ai
quelques options choisissez vous entre
ces deux solutions la première qui
consiste à mettre la main dessus tout de
suite nous pouvons le faire nous les
connaissons mais au risque de laisser
filer des tas d'autres que nous ne
connaissons pas
deuxième option attendre qu'il se
manifeste de façon à pouvoir mettre la
main sur un nombre plus considérable de
gens qui seraient compromis dans la même
entreprise alors c'est une réponse que
je lui ai pas donné tout de suite parce
que je voulais en parler à françois
mitterrand je lui en ai parlé dans
l'avion immédiatement que tu n'écoutes
sommes repartis il m'a dit qu'il allait
réfléchir à cette question de lyon est
saisie temps sur la solution
à peine l'avion le ministre a pu
décoller que vos jours reçoit un rapport
alarmiste des renseignements généraux ce
rapport prévoit le début de
l'insurrection dans un avenir très
proche bonjour dessine aussi tout vous
prévenir paris
j'ai immédiatement
fait venir la secrétaire et je lui ai
dicté la page que le gouverneur général
a signé
et qui se terminer par cette phrase
désormais sommes nous à la veille de la
fin de l'incident ou d'attentats en
algérie il est impossible de l'affirmer
d'une façon absolue mais on peut
vraiment le redouté
ça me paraissait assez clair pour ceux
qui allaient le recevoir
il s'est passé le dimanche
le lundi
je n'avais toujours rien aucune nouvelle
on veut un coup de téléphone vous n'avez
eu aucune réponse aucun écho du côté du
cabinet du ministre du ministre le 2
novembre j'ai reçu une lettre le 2
novembre
à en me disant vous pouvez les coffrets
pas besoin de vous dire que
effectivement
j'étais tout disposé à le faire déjà et
pour cause dès le 10 octobre les six
fils de la toussaint avait fixé la date
de l'insurrection au 1er novembre à zéro
heure date qui ne devait révéler alors
commando ma thune sous pression que six
heures auparavant le nom du cru à un été
abandonnés pour celui de fln front de
libération nationale pour la branche
armée était à hélène armée de libération
nationale
oh non
le 24 octobre les six tiennent une
dernière réunion à alger et en profite
pour faire la photo historique
[Musique]
avec 400 armes essentiellement des
fusils de chasse des bombes artisanales
et moins d'un millier d'hommes et ne
doute pas un instant de l'avenir
vos jours sans que les événements
s'accélèrent comme on lui signale la
présence de 300 tenaga dans les aurès il
provoque une réunion à constantine avec
les responsables politiques et
militaires de la région
[Musique]
deux colonels blanche qui commandait le
secteur m'a dit monsieur le préfet tout
ça c'est des histoires
on est en train d'affabuler il a eu
cette phrase superbe il m'a dit moi je
me balade tous les jours même la nuit
quelques fois dans les aurès jamais je
n'ai vu dans les phares de ma jeep
fellaghas
le l'administrateur daris m'a dit je
confirme entièrement ce qu'a dit le le
colonel blanche
s'il y avait vraiment des insoumis dans
les aurès je le saurai et personne n'y a
cru
le compte à rebours a commencé mais
personne ne le sait hormis une poignée
d'hommes résolu
il court hier quand on écoute jean
vaujour on se rend compte qu'il était
extrêmement bien informé qu'il a prévenu
les autorités et finalement il ya très
peu de réaction finalement oui encore
une fois paris et comment vous expliquez
ça on envoie un rapport qui est
extrêmement alarmistes qui annonce qu'il
va y avoir des choses très très sérieuse
des attentats il a parlé de cette
histoire de bon dans la casbah personnes
se précipitent pour coin des règles des
mesures ce fameux rapport c'est le
rapport du 23 octobre à françois
mitterrand qui est ministre de
l'intérieur et qui vient de venir en
algérie donc le rapport qu'est-ce qu'il
dit le mouvement couvre toute l'algérie
mais
répondant de toute façon c'est quelque
chose qui est venu de l'étranger c'est
ben bella qui
synchronise tout ça du caire le caire
agit sur les populations et puis surtout
le rapport tout bêtement il se perd à
paris ce père pourquoi parce que il ya
cette sacro-sainte politique du
parapluie les attachés de cabinet et
chefs de cabine elle aurait pas des
renvois pas déranger le ministre mais
non on n'y croit pas et pourquoi il ya
ce vaujour banc bien sûr il est le
patron accepté oui mais quand même on
croise les lattes hier on croit les tout
ce qu'ils disent et y compris les
militaires n'ont depuis 1945 il y a eu
ses tifs il y a eu la répression il ya
eu le coup de bâton on les tient bien
ils ne vont pas bouger après tout ce
n'est qu'un flic même peut-être un grand
flic mais c'est un flic exactement
exactement et il n'a pas eu bon là il
n'a pas la considération alors que c'est
véritablement un très haut fonctionnaire
et un homme qui connaît formidablement
bien son affaire et bien
n'a pas l'oreille du ministre alors
juste à la veille du 1er novembre
qu'elle le crua ça représente quoi
t'est-ce quelles sont les forces des ces
types qui se lancent ces hommes qui se
lancent dans cette dans cette aventure
depuis l' os ils ont recruté selon la
méthode pyramidale c'est à dire qu'il y
en a un qui connaît trois copains les
trois copains recrute 3 autres et
personne ne se connaît entre il ya juste
le l'homme du départ le suivant et après
trois autres la zone tout est cloisonné
bon alors qu'est ce qu'il y à il y a
deux forces principales il ya les 450
hommes des kabyles parce que krim
belkacem et le sergent ou à branne aussi
un homme qui vient de de l'armée
française et qui a très bien combattu
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale eh
bien ils ont
créé des groupes des groupes armés est
depuis longtemps parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que au 1er novembre 1954 krim
belkacem lui tient le mât qui depuis
déjà sept ans pour des tas de raisons je
peux pas vous raconter ici ce serait
beaucoup trop long mais oui cic vraiment
oui hors-la-loi
lanceur l'algérie à l'angola 450 hommes
chez lui en kabylie il ya les hommes de
ben boulaïd ans et aurait ce dont je
vous ai parlé c'est aurès sauvages alors
là il ya 400 hommes de très politisé
réunis en cellule en groupe d'action et
la chose encore plus importante c'est
que ben boulaïd lui dispose d'une
réserve d'armes de caches d'armes qui
datent de l'époque de l'eau sdd
récupération pendant la guerre etc c'est
la plus importante de l'algérie enfin
c'est pas quelque chose d'énorme et puis
alors alger il n'y a pas grand-chose à
alger il ya rabah bitat tu qui a créé
ces
ateliers de
fabrication de bombes dont jean vaujour
a eu connaissance et a eu un des
exemplaires bon mais il n'y a pas
énormément de choses il y a tout de même
quelque chose qui a pu obtenir boudiaf
au caire c'est que benbella qui était le
patron de l'ol lui a donné des caches
relativement importante avec quelques
une mitraillette destin à l'époque donc
qu'ils ont en gros au 1er novembre 54 ce
qu'ils vont déclencher la toussaint
rouge
il a dit d'une façon un petit peu un
petit peu outré c'est à peu près 1000
hommes mais avec vraiment quoi 400 armes
500 armes grand maximum on peut dire
qu'il ya pas d'armes il n'y a pas
d'argent et surtout il n'y a pas de
soutien populaire parce que parce que le
peuple les connais pas encore mais il ya
la volonté des six fils de la toussaint
et puis la volonté des trois du caire et
voilà il fait ils vont mettre le feu aux
poudres en faisant dix ont
éclaté un gros pétard mais comme le
disait le président mao la planète et
sèche donc ça devient flamber
[Musique]
dimanche 31 octobre l'algérie française
vit ses derniers instants de quiétude
dans l'eau des rebelles s'apprêtent à
passer à l'action
[Musique]
l'insurrection démarre prématurément à
23h45 dans la région de boufarik
abraham seconde belkacem krim attaque à
cazères six fusées 4 mitraillette sur un
fléau poste gardent la coopérative
d'agrumes est incendiée ainsi que l'
usine de papier de ma bague
à la même heure rabah bitat attaque sans
succès la caserne de blida et se
retirant les 103 morts
vers 00h30 de ferme soit attaqué entre
coulisses et bosquets et un européen et
tué devant la gendarmerie de cassaigne
à zéro heure 45 des bons mecs à alger à
l' usine à gaz pétrole maury à la radio
à cette heure-là mais aures n'ont pas
encore bougé
le jeune sous préfet une jandol planque
oppose depuis 18 mois qu'a su nouer des
liens avec la population
ron hyne batna après avoir dîné à
constantine avec son ami le préfet
dupuch
j'arrive à la sous-préfecture de batna
qui se trouvait dans une grande place il
était à peu près une heure quinze
je dois la vie à sept heures parce que
derrière la murette à 8 mètres de moi il
y avait à lakhdar à la tête d'un
commando de six personnes qui avaient
mission de me tuer
mais qui ne vais me tuer qu'à 3 heures
du matin au moment de la taxe
généralisée sur ben
à jacques nar a hésité paraît-il pendant
quelque temps et finalement soucieux de
d'observer la discipline
il ne m'a pas tiré j'ai pu pénétrer
ainsi dans la sous-préfecture de batna
et je commençais à me déshabiller le
pauvre lui donner le détail
lorsque retentit
le téléphone et ce coup de téléphone est
très important c'est celui de prix yonne
le commissaire central de biskra qui
ensuite été chef de cabinet dtz à l'ange
bleu
épris yonne m'a téléphoné il était à peu
près deux heures en me disant
il vient y avoir de gros incidents à
biskra ont attaqué la couenne mixte on a
attaqué le centrales électriques il ya
des blessés je tiens tout de suite à
vous prennez
je raccroche aux ici tout est là je dois
dire que j'ai hésité quelques secondes
parce que où j'étais un bon petit
fonctionnaire tranquille et paisible et
je me couvrait je téléphonais à dupuch
du gouvernement général et puis j'ai
décidé que il fallait agir immédiatement
sur place que s'il y avait quelque chose
à biskra il y avait quelque chose à
batna et étaient bonnes tout de suite à
bourgeois bourgeois était le capitaine
des gardes mobiles comme très remarquée
et je vais du bourgeois état d' alerte
tout le monde prêt intervenez
soyez prêt il ya peut-être des rebelles
en ville il va prendre une explication
mais il a déclenché la sirène
les lumières se sont allumées et les
gars mobiles ont sorti les
automitrailleuses près intervenait ce
qui fait qu'en quelques minutes
batna à 2 heures du matin s'est éveillée
et les sept ou huit commandos qui
étaient prêts à attaquer batna a tué
surtout les militaires car il avait lors
de ménager les suivez moi j'étais
considéré comme un mini tu es tout les
mangeant du commando et surtout eu ben
boulaïd sont rendus compte que on
connait c'est quelque chose que leur
présence était sans doute connu et il a
fait partie la fameuse fusée rouge qui a
indiqué rob lee immédiate au lieu de
faire partir la fusée bleue qui
déclenchait la taxe généralisée sur
matin
voilà très rapidement qui a pas eu de
vrais affrontements n'y a pas eu la
preuve y a pas eu d'affrontement si ce
n'est qu'on a tiré sur chef d'état major
et que les deux petites sentinelle qui
se trouvait
devant la caserne ont été assassinés
sans pouvoir se défendre car comble de
bêtise il était de garde il avait un
fusil mais les cartouches étaient
enveloppés dans une enveloppe de toile
il n'avait pas le droit de s'en sortir
ils ont été abattus sans pouvoir se
détend
mais autre village des aurès ne sont pas
épargnés à khenchela le lieutenant
d'arnaud commandant la place et un
soldat sans tuer à risque où tu fous
tout soit à 15 ans retour est coupé du
monde
[Musique]
à 7 heures du matin le car qui assure la
liaison iskra harris est stoppé dans les
gorges du trient pas nominé
passagers doivent descendre le kite
sadok l'instituteur monroe et sa femme
sont abattu d'une rafale selmana monroe
survivra
dans le constantinois les gendarmeries
de condé smendou khroub saint-charles
essuyé des coups de feu
en kabylie et sabotages détruisent des
lignes téléphoniques des incendies
ravagent des poux de liège et de tabac
mais caserne de gendarmerie sont
attaqués de garde champêtre 100 tués au
total on dénombre huit morts des
dizaines d'attentats revendiqués par des
petits groupes qui se réclament du fln
ce qui est important c'est que on se
rend compte que ces petits groupes dont
on sait on se doute qu'ils sont pas très
importants ils sont déterminés ils vont
contre la représentation de ce qu'est le
fait colonial les casernes les
commissariats de police la commune mixte
reine celle à la caserne un lieutenant
qui est abattu autre chose on l'ordre
était surtout de ne pas toucher aux
européens mai d'abattre bien sûr des
soldats français voilà et puis à 7
heures du matin c'est ce que la
métropole retiendra il ya ce petit quart
qui prend la route biskra harris et qui
dans les gorges de tyrannie mines est
attaqué et ça ça va faire vraiment
l'effet du bombe psychologique au total
combien une trentaine quarantaine de
d'incidents recensés sur l'ensemble du
territoire absolument c'est
véritablement pas grand-chose la chose
qui est la plus importante c'est que il
y à quelque part une tête qui a décidé
que tel jour à telle heure aux quatre
coins de l'algérie et de l'est à l'ouest
on pouvait montrer que le peuple se
révolte est le peuple c'est beaucoup
dire c'est une poignée d'hommes mais une
poignée d'hommes qui sont dirigés
soulèvement même sort alors est ce que
vous allez dire est ce que c'est une
insurrection est ce que c'est un
soulèvement une insurrection non dans le
sens soulèvement visant à renverser le
pouvoir ce pouvoir établi et qui est
honni mais oui dans le sens général de
l'insurrection égale révolte c'est la
révolte d'une poignée d'hommes et non
une insurrection populaire ela va être
tout le problème c'est pour cette
poignée d'hommes qui sont tous issus de
l'organisation spéciale il va falloir
ramener cette population à la révolution
et ça ça n'a pas être facile et il faut
employer les moyens les plus
les plus dures et les plus atroces et la
suite de la guerre donc on peut dire sur
le 1er novembre sur le plan militaire
avec des guillemets semi échec sur le
plan politique retentissement énorme oui
et puis surtout qu'il ya une autre chose
c'est que radio le caire dans la matinée
annonce avec une précision que
n'ont pas pu le savoir par la radio et
par quoi que ce soit donc eu le caire
savez avec précision les attentats de
toute cette nuit et là c'est une
victoire psychologique
énorme et c'est une grave erreur des
politiciens français que de dire parce
que ça les arrange il y à là dessous la
main de l'étranger en connaîtrons le
complot de l'étranger c'est tellement
facile
[Musique]
on n'a pas eu l'impression dé si vous
voulez que c'était une insurrection on a
cru que c'était
un trouble grave à trouve grave à
l'ordre public aussi bien à alger qu'à
constantine que moi batman dans les
premiers jours je ne me suis pas rendu
compte immédiatement de la gravité de la
situation et j'ai cru qu'on avait nommé
prisés ce n'est quand on a arrêté les
premières personnes que on s'est rendu
compte de l'existence réelle d'un cru à
de toute une métastase
insurrectionnel sur l'ensemble de
l'algérie et qu'il faudrait beaucoup de
temps pour la faire disparaître
jerry a fait des obsèques solennelles
aux victimes de la vague d'attentats qui
dans la nuit du 1er novembre a déferlé
sur divers points du territoire au cours
d'une trentaine d'attaqués sept
personnes avaient trouvé la mort
à grand peine que l'on réussit à évacuer
madame monroe une jeune institutrice
grièvement blessés a appris aux côtés de
son mari animée
pour répondre à ce plan d'incitation
concertée des renforts des dépôts totaux
dépêchés vers les principaux points
névralgiques
à bord d'un hélicoptère l'envoyé du
ministre de l'intérieur survolé la
réunion ii n'aurait ainsi pas le foyer
de l'invitation la première difficulté
que j'ai eue c'est que j'ai constaté que
les hauts personnages de l'armée n'y
croyais pas ils n'ont pas pris ça au
sérieux
sur place et à paris quand je suis
arrivé à alger en disant je le mardi 2
au soir une réunion avec léonard et puis
les rôles sérieux et s'est dit au
général derrière voici ce que j'ai
obtenu comme renfort renforts de troupes
il m'a à peu près dit que celui/celle
police avait là rien que c'était
absolument pas important et brusquement
le lendemain ou le surlendemain je ne me
rappelle plus exactement alors que
j'étais dans ma chambre vous palais
d'été
je reçois goûter les foies daniel darc
qui m'a dit
je souhaite pouvoir le plus vite
possible parce que le général serrières
me demande me dit qu'il va lui falloir
deux divisions pour reconquérir leur
aise
je garde c'est je garde cette phrase
présente à l'esprit de qui ce moment là
j'ai hurlé le führer pourquoi de
divisions alors que la veille on me
disait qu'on a besoin de rien et
reconquérir le rsa signifier qu'on
l'avait abandonnée
à paris pierre mendès france affirme
l'algérie c'est la france on ne transige
pas quand il s'agit de défendre
l'intégrité de la république
françois mitterrand est sur la même
longueur d'onde on s'attaque quant à nos
compatriotes algériens les meurtriers et
les émeutiers ont dressé contre eu la
force française cette force défendra la
justice en maintenant l'unité nationale
en protégeant ceux qui travaillent et
ceux qui peinent en rétablissant la paix
civique appuyé sur la volonté de
concorde et de progrès de l'immense
majorité du peuple elle interdira aux
agitateurs le plus souvent recrutés à
l'étranger la poursuite d'une oeuvre de
destruction
si les meneurs ont voulu alerter
l'opinion internationale
à la veille d'une session des nations
unies ils ont eu tort
l'algérie c'est la france et la france
ne reconnaîtra pas chez elle d'autres
autorités que la sienne
à la fin du mois de novembre françois
mitterrand retourne en algérie en
particulier dans les aurès
[Applaudissements]
sommes donc au milieu du troisième jour
ce trop bref voyage à travers la région
qui a le plus ouvert la tentative
insurrectionnel monfils
cependant il semble bien qu'à travers
toute l'algérie est spécifiquement dans
ces lieux en direction de biskra jeunes
cela se passe là on évolue le vélv up
contre celui qu'on appelait l'étranger
où l'occupant de français la population
n'a pas compris ce langage des rennais
française elle n'a donc pas suivi il n'a
pas obéi au mot d'ordre de ci de là elle
a hésité
mère dans deux endroits nous frapperons
donc pas d'une manière collective nous
nous éviterons tout ce qui pourrait
apparaître comme une sorte d'état de
guerre nous ne voulons pas mais douch
attirons manière implacable
sans autre souci que celui de la justice
et à la circonstance la justice existe
la rigueur des responsables et tous ceux
qui seront souscrits
agissant d'une façon évidente par le
moyen des armes contre eux hollande doit
savoir que le risque pour une immense
dans leur vie dans leur bien et si nous
le regrettons puisque ce sont nos
concitoyens ils sont soumis comme tout
criminel à la loi la loi sera appliquée
groupe a donné des consignes de
bienveillance
extrêmement strictes il voulait que
l'ordre soit rétabli
dans les aurès d'une manière légale bien
entendu mais sans aucune faiblesse
comme la guerre d'algérie situe son
point de départ que ce soit une exacte
donc ça s'émeut c'est sensationnel
au 1er novembre
1954 et que j'étais misé intérieur bien
entendu on s'est tourné vers moi j'ai
très bien accepté cette responsabilité
merkel s'est elle n'a venise non pas la
responsabilité de la guerre mais la
responsabilité de prendre les mesures
qui convenait pour faire face à cette
situation qui de nos positions et une
hostilité larvée il se signalait de
temps à autre par des incidents ça avait
tout d'un coup des incidents coordonnées
une début de son appui elle était en
effet bien que j'ai donc bien là dessus
bien mais censure et moi nous sommes
très bien entendus et je dois dire que
une fois passée cette nuit de la
toussaint ou 17 morts sept morts cinq
dans le département du côté des aurès
diamant le département de constantine et
deux bandeaux fortement d'alger et
l'autre dans le département de rond
puisque c'étaient des départements
entre ce moment là elle départ de l'est
mais les sens et il n'y a pas eu de
il a ici et là des incidents que ça
pouvait être considérée comme grave mais
finir plus d'attentats j'aurais
surveille guerre d'algérie un important
engagement a eu lieu dans les environs
de tours unités parachutistes a pénétré
dans le village d'accueil en flammes
[Musique]
les hors la loi ont laissé quelques
morts et plusieurs blessés
ratissage dans la montagne
interrogatoires des suspects les
récitations d'identité les habitants
appellent aux populations à se réfugier
dans les secteurs de sécurité toutes ces
mesures ne manqueront pas de ramener le
calme dans l'oreille
mais pierre mendès france et françois
mitterrand savent qu'elles ne résoudront
pas la question algérienne par la seule
politique du bâton au conseil des
ministres du 5 janvier françois
mitterrand présente un programme de
réformes économiques sociales et
culturelles dans l'esprit du ministre
les musulmans doivent bénéficier des
mêmes droits que les européens
étaient dramatiques parce que se
plaindraient fort moi elle était
j'appelle ça aujourd'hui une réformette
quand on regarde ce à la lumière de ce
qui s'est passé depuis faidherbe
ceyzériat du tout mais ce que l'on
mesure mal aujourd'hui c'est la
difficulté qu'on avait même de faire une
réforme est alors c'est sûr ces projets
que ma naissance est tombé et 20 sur la
politique nord africaine du gouvernement
a sonné le glas du cabinet mendès-france
y abandonne le pouvoir après huit mois
bien remplie
[Musique]
je n'ai je n'ai rien à dire
moment nous sommes
je ne cache pas mon émotion
je ne cache pas non plus ma peine
non pour moi bien entendu
mais parce que je crois que l'entreprise
à laquelle s'était attaché le
gouvernement que je présidais était
bonne pour le pays
et que je regrette qu'elle soit
maintenant interrompu
les réactions en france du gouvernement
aussi bien de camalès france qui prend
du conseil que france invité en chemise
à l'intérieur c'est de répondre ce qui
vient de se passer en algérie est grave
mais l'algérie c'est la france il n'y a
pas de ces cessions possibles donc à
l'époque personne n'envisage une seconde
que ce qui va se passer
on clanchin une guerre de huit ans
absolument pas parce que
la guerre on y pense absolument pas on
conseille on prend la faire comme on le
considère la faire comme du maintien de
l'ordre
et on ne va pas regarder les causes et
la profondeur de la surrection par
exemple vous avez vu les titres des
journaux on arrête tous les gens qui
sont fichés au mtld non là ça rend un
service formidable au fln qui lui est
déjà en opposition avec la soul n'a rien
à voir absolument pas alors il ya la
politique d'alger ça va être d'imposer à
la france
cette politique qui est pas de réforme
de faire des réformes maintenant ce
serait donner une prime à la révolte et
ça on n'en veut pas dès le début il ya
deux camps même de voler dans la
politique du gouvernement madness france
a rétabli l'ordre et ça c'est le boulot
si j'ose dire il me intérieure et deux
on met en place avec des réformes les
deux sont simultanés alors d'abord le
maintien de l'ordre dans votre bouquin
vous dit que quand même que le musée
l'intérieur françois mitterrand était
partisan du maintien de l'ordre assez
musclé oui absolument mais s'est il fait
du fait son travail de ministre de
l'intérieur de l'époque mais vous avez
en face ces militaires qui disaient et
la veille encore tout va bien de notre
foi alors le général shir yole
commandant en chef qu'on appelle bavard
parce que c'est un homme un petit peu
fort qui va essayer de passer les aurès
au peigne fin vous avez vu la
configuration des aurès passer ça au
peigne fin c'est vraiment de la folie
douce alors on va quand même pas assez
dans les villages et dans les villages
qu'est ce qui se passe des exactions
cette population qui n'est pas pour ce
mouvement au départ il va se retrouver
prise entre l'arbre et les corses et ça
c'est regrettable mais basculera pas se
passer tout de suite mais
basculera de la même façon que la
population d'alger après la bataille
d'alger en 1956 basculera du côté du fln
parce que il ya sept ans cet engrenage
attentats répression et répression c'est
un peu plus musclée ce plan de réforme
qui essaye de mettre en place au
gouvernement mades que présente françois
mitterrand conseillers des ministres
début janvier est ce qu'il est ce que
ces trois tard est-ce que c'est
complètement chéméré qu'est-ce qu'il a
eu aucune chance de parce que c'est trop
tard pour les réformes à ce que la
guerre est inévitable mais les réformes
il faudrait qu'elle soit appliquée je
peux pas je ne fais pas partie de la
tribu des yaka et des faucons
je ne sais pas les réformes elles ne
sont pas appliquées la politique des
groupes de pression algérois et lg rien
c'est de dire pas de réforme les
réformes on verra plus tard pas de
réformes tant que l'ordre n'est pas
rétabli et c'est très exactement ce qui
se passe l'ordre établi à turin grosso
modo sauf dans les aurès mais il ya
toujours pas de réforme non absolument
pas ne serait-ce que le
statut de 1947 parce que très peu de
temps avant le déclenchement du 1er
novembre 1954
pierre mendès-france a reçu ferhat abbas
avec
dans des circonstances tout à fait
entouré de secret et qu'est ce qu'ils
demandent ferhat abbas demande une seule
chose pour président du conseil je vous
en supplie appliquer le statut de 1947
et ne fait plus d'élections truquées
comme celle quelqu'un que l'on vient de
voir alors ça ne se produira jamais et
puis ma ds france est lâché en
particulier on reprend on retrouve son
nom par rené meyer l'homme qui dit
toujours nous n'accepterons jamais
l'assimilation et il les rend il est
renversé et qu'est ce qui dit et pour
moi ce sera le mot de la fin en quittant
le gouvernement en afrique du nord ou
bien ce sera la politique d'entente ou
bien la politique de répression et de
force avec toutes ces horribles
conséquences c'est ce qui s'est passé
les neufs chutent historiquement connu
un destin tragique mourad didouche et
tué en opération en 1955 mostefa ben
boulaïd sont sur un poste émetteur
piéger par les services français en 1956
larbi benmhidi est arrêté par les hommes
de bigeard 1957 on ne le reverra jamais
mohamed khider trésorier du fln est
assassiné à madrid en 1967
belkacem krim est retrouvée étranglée
dans une chambre d'hôtel à francfort en
1970 où un mec boudiaf président de la
république est assassiné à alger en 1992
rabah bitat d'aujourd'hui alger ben
bella a fait une vingtaine d'années de
prison ait ahmed après la prison et
l'exil se bat aujourd'hui pour une
algérie démocratique
[Musique]
et pour terminer les livres qui nous ont
aidés à préparer cette émission pour
ceux qui veulent en savoir plus et
d'abord et avant tout le livre d'yves
courrière la guerre d'algérie l'histoire
la guerre d'algérie des fils de la
toussaint ça c'est le tome 1 donc qui
concerne directement évidemment
l'émission de ce soir paru chez fayard
il ya 25 ans et qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
chez laffont en collection bouquins les
fils de la toussaint d'yves courrière le
livre indispensable
le point de vue d'un historien algérien
mohamed harbi historien et acteurs
d'ailleurs paru chez complexe la guerre
commence en algérie le 1er novembre 1954
deux histoires très synthétique et très
bonne de l'oeil de la guerre d'algérie
une paru au point en point histoire
histoire la guerre d'algérie bernard
droz et vine le vert excellente synthèse
et celle de benjamin stora histoire de
la guerre d'algérie paru à la découverte
enfin deux témoignages celui de hocine
aït ahmed mémoire d'un combattant
l'esprit d'indépendance
42,52 paru chez sylvie messinger il ya
quelques années hocine ait ahmed vous
l'avez vu dans l'émission c'est l'un des
side dans les parent dont l'un des six
chefs historiques un des six fils de la
toussaint et c'est son témoignage sur
son itinéraire de combattants l'autre
témoignage c'est celui de jean vaujour
que vous avez vu également dans
l'émission de la révolte à la révolution
au premier jour la guerre d'algérie paru
chez albin michel il ya quelques années
où il reprend et développe naturellement
tout ce qu'il savait sur les préparatifs
de l'insurrection enfin un dossier
préparé par la revue l'histoire les
drames de la guerre d'algérie dossier
sur la guerre d'algérie donc dans la
revue l'histoire du mois d'octobre voilà
le mois prochain les brûleurs de
l'histoire seront consacré un dossier
particulièrement délicat l'épuration
bonsoir
[Musique]
m
nous
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]